Yeah,
Yeah.
You'll see me at that crowd.
And I said, Thank you. That's awesome.
Thank you very much.
All right, let's go in there.
No. Yes. Oh, yes.
Oh, yes.
You're going in here.
We are not going all going in there.
You know, we do not go back.
We do not go back. Look, the car is gone.
It's gone by car.
We run. We do not run. We stand our ground.
Yes, I'm in there, but hi
risk know we long on the hospital.
And besides.
Annie is in there.
Oh yeah. And he is in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. She's. She's in here.
So why don't we just go in there we go.
She brought out with her hind, like,
right now.
Here we go. It. Yeah.
What a great idea.
This has a good guy
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
This will be my Venom 3 teaser video.
I'll explain what's going on.
There's been a lot of rumors
about Spider-Man crossover in Tom Hardy
in the directors in the past,
like Andy's Serkis, previous director
have been talking about crossing over
with the Spider-Man character,
and there's a lots of questions
about which version of Spider-Man,
because this is connected
to the Morbius movie.
And there were all kinds of Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield Easter eggs
during the Morbius trailers,
but then they re-edited
the movie
to make it a little bit different.
I'll explain what's going on with that.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Unless there's some big delay.
Venom three is supposed to come out
October 2024, so it's coming out
long before Avengers
Kang Dynasty in Secret Wars.
There have been lots of rumors
about Tom Holland
signing his megadeal for Spider-Man 4.
We know that he's done it,
but there's also rumors about him
being one of the leads.
One of the main characters in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty.
So when we talk about Tom Holland
getting a version of the Symbiote,
I think they're actually going to do that
during Secret Wars now.
I think they're actually trying to do
the comic book thing
where he gets the alien costume,
quote unquote,
as they called it originally in the comics
before it became Venom.
During their new version
of Secret Wars in the movies.
There was a lot of fan
art of that a long time ago,
but we just didn't know how
that was going to play out
until Kim and Foggy confirmed
how they were going to do
Kang Dynasty in Secret Wars.
In the Avengers movies.
This is Tom Hardy teasing Big Multiverse
crossover.
Previously before Spider-Man,
No Way Home came out.
There's a Venom verse, you know that
there's a there's a spider-verse
as multiverse is
there's all kinds of canon and lore
and mythology to explore
both laterally and forward in time.
And I think with the right people
and the right planning,
it's about making the right choices
at the right time,
even with foresight of understanding
where things may go.
And so it's a combination of all of those
in the alchemy of what it will be.
Clearly, before Spider-Man,
No Way Home came out,
you can see that
Sony was trying to figure out
how they're going to connect
the Sony universe of Marvel movies
with the MCU.
Kevin Feige,
you talked about that previously,
that Venom and Spider-Man
would eventually crossover,
but then revealed how those details
were going to work.
Then we got Spider-Man No Way Home
in Venom, Let There Be Carnage.
There were a couple of very big Tom
Holland and Venom crossover moments
as it relates to any characters
that Marvel Studios hasn't
has brought to the screen yet.
Having been in Marvel for 20 years,
I wouldn't dismiss anything.
I wouldn't rule anything out
when and how and where remains to be seen.
A Spider Man Menace.
But rest assured your viewers,
we're in the Daily Bugle.
Well, not until we went.
Oh, I.
Well, why five years? It's a long time.
And you should
go to New York, speak to this
Spider-Man.
Reportedly during Venom.
Let there be Carnage,
because that came out before Spider-Man.
No way home.
There was an even bigger Venom
Spider-Man crossover.
But Marvel had the Sony people change that
so that he just saw him on screen.
They didn't actually meet each other
together on screen yet.
And then when we get to Spider-Man,
no way home,
he just lost a piece of the symbiote
inside the MCU.
I think just to leave that wide open track
to deal with that however they wanted to.
Like,
we'll give him the symbiote at some point,
but we haven't completely figured
that out yet.
Then during the Morbius movie,
we had all the Andrew Garfield and Tobey
Maguire Easter eggs.
There were some Tom Holland
Easter eggs in there too, for the MCU,
Spider-Man, the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
suit in the version of the Daily Bugle
is Tobey Maguire's.
But the version of Oscorp
looks like Andrew Garfield's
one from The Amazing Spider-Man two.
I already talked about all the Easter
eggs here, but the extra Easter eggs
they include on this version of the Daily
Bugle with the logo from the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movies or Rhino
and Black Cat Easter Eggs.
Like, is the Black Cat going to show up
during this movie?
Is the Rhino going to show up
Sony is developing a spin off movie
for the Black Cat character.
I don't know when we're going to see that,
but I believe that's what those Easter
eggs are meant to tease.
As for Rhino,
I have no idea what they're going to do
with that character
or which version it would be,
because the last time we saw the Rhino,
it was really, really silly.
I have a hard time
believing that they would bring that back
unless they do a slightly
different version.
There were a lot of clues early on that
the Morbius movie
was actually happening inside
a similar universe.
Is the Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man.
If it's been a while
since you've seen Amazing
Spider-Man two during that movie,
you might remember they referenced
Morbius in Venom specifically,
along with a bunch of other teasers
for other characters and things buried
in Harry Osborn's Oscorp files
like Zoom and Enhance.
Here they have a Morbius project
that they were working on.
They had a Venom project.
So had they made Amazing Spider-Man
three with Andrew Garfield,
they would have given him the Venom
symbiote during that movie
and he would have faced
a version of the Sinister Six
as they teased in the Post-Credits scene.
But we also would have seen a version
of Black Cat show up, and then obviously
they were trying to set up a whole bunch
of other spin off movies, too.
Plus there was that teaser where he talked
about wanting to fight an alien,
an alien made out of black goo once.
Oh, no way.
I found Alien two on Earth then in space.
Oh, yeah, he was purple.
I want to find an alien.
We do know that Marvel plans on
bringing Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man back during Secret Wars,
but that's more like a multiverse Avengers
type of movie.
I don't think they're going to be a Kang
Dynasty.
I think they're just
going to be in secret wars
because there's reports about them
using that movie to bring back
a lot of the legacy characters
like Fox characters,
Fox X-Men characters, Fox, Fantastic Four.
It'll be sort of like a swansong
for those characters
before you see a bunch of new versions
in the MCU, primarily
X-Men characters, because we'll already
have seen the new fantastic Four.
But that's one of the reasons
why you're seeing so much.
Hugh Jackman Wolverine in the Deadpool
three movie Before Kang Dynasty
and Secret Wars will finally see them
pay off that deleted scene
when they planned on crossing over
Hugh Jackman with Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
in the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man movies.
But Hugh Jackman, at the time
when they were going to film that cameo,
his costume wasn't ready, so they just had
to remove the scene outright.
Now they can do that
during a version of Secret Wars.
And what happened with the Morbius movie
is that they kept re-editing that movie.
They removed so many Easter eggs
for Spider-Man out of that,
mostly because they sense that movie
wasn't that great in Spider-Man.
No Way Home had just come out
and was earning so much money.
They just wanted to leave it alone.
As much as possible.
Like let's not mess with Spider-Man,
no way home.
Success earned all the money and we'll
just release Morbius quietly over here.
But during that movie
also they had a big crossover
with the MCU version of Vulture.
They confirmed that
it was the Michael Keaton MCU.
Vulture from Spider-Man.
Homecoming has to do with Spider-Man,
I think.
But I think a bunch of guys like us
should team up could do some good.
Intriguing.
So again, right now it just seems like
they want to say that Venom three
if it is going to feature Spider-Man
cameo with him
meeting Spider-Man on screen,
it will be the Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
But it could always wind up
being the Andrew Garfield Spider-Man.
You remember the Sony does have plans
for all those spinoff Sinister Six movies.
That's what that Vulture cameo scene
was meant to set up.
Like we should team up.
Sony has plans for a billion
of their own Spider-Man movies,
like they have the Madame Web movie
that they're working on right now
with a bunch of Tobey Maguire
Easter eggs during it.
So it just seems like
they have Easter eggs for every Spider-Man
ever in all of their movies.
Also, during Venom, Let There Be Carnage,
they said that this whole teaser
with the Toxin character,
which is meant to be the child
of the carnage symbiote,
just like carnage is meant to be the child
of the venom symbiote.
At the end of the movie,
Detective Hooligans,
I started flashing, then just teasing that
something had happened to him.
I think they'll follow that up
with either a version of talks
and because many years ago
when they started doing
all the Venom movies
that he's doing all the different
iterations of the symbiotes one of the
I think our great hopes for future
films is other articulations of Venom.
But typically with the third movie
in trilogies, they try to go as big
as possible, big
as crossovers as possible, which is why
there's all this talk about them having
some kind of actual Spider-Man crossover,
which they could just wind up
doing at the end of the movie.
Let me know in the comments how you think
they'll actually try to pull that off.
And do you expect to see
Tom Hardy's venom in a version
of Kang Dynasty or Secret Wars?
I've already done
a couple of videos about Spider-Man four.
I'll post links for that
down in the description below,
because we knew that Tom Holland
was going to come back
and do those movies.
But it includes a new trilogy
of solo Spider-Man movies
like We All kind of Expected,
made by Marvel and Kevin Feige,
like the previous Spider-Man movies,
same exact deal as they had before.
For those in two Avengers
movies for Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty in Avengers 6 Secret Wars.
Beyond that, when it comes to minor
crossovers, for those of
you asking for him to show up in Daredevil
Born Again, it'd be awesome
if Spider-Man showed up during Daredevil
episodes.
Daredevil is definitely going
to be showing up during the new Spider-Man
movies.
Tom Holland's New Deal
right now is just for the movie stuff,
not for the TV, the Disney Plus stuff
or the one off crossovers in other movies.
And I just posted a bunch of Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania Post-Credits
scene videos
about everything that they were teasing.
With Kang you can click here
for my Post-Credits scene video
and click here for my Full Breakdown
and Easter Eggs video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.